meeting of the minds which is Carnegie
Mellon's campus-wide undergraduate
research symposium I think is probably
the quintessential Carnegie Mellon event
it's one of the few times when the
entire campus can join together under
one roof with all of the disciplines
represented to really share our
intellectual passions and discoveries
many people think about undergraduate
research in relation to Sciences and
engineering and they rarely give it a
thought in terms of humanities in the
arts and even business and one of the
real earmarks of our distinctive
programs is that it's open to all of the
disciplines students can come up with an
idea and it can be an idea in their
field of formal interest or it can be
just an idea that they have that may not
be connected to their major the
undergraduate research sponsors two
major programs one is search and search
stands for small undergraduate research
grants students can apply for this
during any course any year in their
undergraduate education the other major
program that we sponsor is the summer
undergraduate research fellowship better
known as serf I thought it was such an
amazing opportunity to get paid to
explore my own work and really know who
I am get to know who I am as an artist
the serf grant allowed me to stay here
and work on my project as if it were a
full-time job without the serf grand I
wouldn't have been able to make such
headway with my projects and we do have
a number of corporate participants in
meeting of the minds who sponsor
competitions which only adds to the
excitement of the day so today I'm here
for the meeting of the minds as part of
our ongoing relationship with Carnegie
Mellon this year I have an opportunity
to be a judge looking at the
environmental ideas that Carnegie Mellon
students have come up with with
undergraduate research a little
relatively small amount of money can go
a very long way it can enable students
to engage in a creative undertaking that
would not be possible without those
funds undergraduate research resources
mean the entire difference between hobby
shopping and full-time commitment to
serious research the fact that our
support is helping this helping these
students is so gratifying we get a lot
of thank-you notes from the from the
students that receive the grants and we
save them because winning someday we're
gonna have a actual autograph of a Nobel
Prize winner or a Tony winner or an
Oscar winner we're convinced of its that
we have them all
you